bonjour je me demande ça pour rien et je
suis un étudiant de cinquième secondaire
en tant qu'élève je m'attends à ce que
une école soit un lieu où un jeune peut
créer des liens entre personnes et
découvrir sa place dans le monde
ce n'est pas supposé être un endroit
dangereux
cependant on en entend de plus en plus
parler des écoles qui sont attaqués le
fait qu'il faut demander à son ami s'il
a survécu sa journée à l'école est
complètement absurde mais fait de plus
en plus partie de la vie quotidienne de
certains adolescents à quasiment chaque
semaine on entend la nouvelle qui n'est
qu'à lui un lieu public fut attaquée
résultant des blessés est souvent des
morts
lorsqu'on voit ces nouvelles ont plus
les yeux on comprend pas vraiment cette
violence mais on finit par oublier et
bien sûr qu'on oublie ici au canada on
est chanceux les fusillés nous affecte
beaucoup moins bien que ces chiffres
soient un peu vieux ils demandent quand
même la distinction claire dans le
nombre de fusillades des deux pays
debout ce soir sur cette scène je n'ai
pas peur
alors pourquoi est-ce que je sois je
choisis ce sujet eh bien je pense que la
majorité d'entre vous présent ce soir
sont familiers avec fusillade à parkland
diane quelques semaines mais qu'est ce
qui à propos de cette fusillade qui
maintenant marquer qui a fait réaliser
que je devrais écrire mon discours non
sur la cybercriminalité mais sur les
fusillades scolaire et bien sa cause que
cette fusillade s'est déroulée à 25 km
de l'école d'une de mes amis et j'ai eu
vraiment peur et c'est cette peur qui
m'a incité à écrire ses discours qui a
fait réaliser qu'il fallait adresser la
situation mais comment pouvons nous
adresser
comment pouvons-nous l'améliorer eh bien
il va commencer au début à la source du
problème
le fait que les armes à feu soit si
accessible aux états unis ne fait qu
empirer la situation pour vous démontrer
que le contrôle sur les armes à feu est
une pomme et valade solution je vais
poser le contraste entre les états unis
et l'australie en 1996 dans la région de
la tasmanie
trente cinq personnes ont perdu la vie à
cause d'une fusillade
35 le gouvernement australien
complètement traumatisée a décidé
d'instaurer une loi qui interdirait
toute arme semi-automatique et fusils de
chasse
ils ont aussi instauré une période de 28
jours avant d'accorder une arme à une
personne pour s'assurer que cette
personne est responsable et des raisons
valables devoir s'armer autodéfense en
australie n'est pas une bonne raison et
ça la marche et les chiffres ont
descendu et je sais qu un contre
argument à se contrôler et que
l'australie et les états unis sont deux
pays complètement différent et je vous
la corde mais sont quand même d'une
nation où une population est gouverné
par des lois donc en interdisant les
armes à feu en les plantant cette loi il
doit y avoir une sorte de changement il
doit y avoir une amélioration à la
situation présente une autre solution
plutôt évidente augmenter le niveau de
sécurité dans le temps lisez dans les
écoles
ça peut sembler banal mais c'est un réel
problème surtout aux états unis
mes amis américains mais raconte des
histoires d'horreur de personnes qui ne
connaissent pas qui marche le campus ou
même une fois une personne est venue
s'asseoir avec eux durant la pause
puisqu'il ya personne pour les empêcher
de le faire juste en mettant une ou deux
personnes des gardes de sécurité aux
entrées va empêcher les inconnus
d'entrer sur le campus
il fera en sorte que les écoles seront
beaucoup beaucoup plus sécuritaire ce
sont des idées simples peut-être pas des
plus innovatrices mais qui sont
efficaces
cependant personne semble vouloir les
implanter à sa cause d'un manque de
d'éducation par rapport aux sujets un
manque de communication sur qu'est ce
qui se passe et c'est ceci qui m'amène à
mon dernier point je sais que les
fusillades sont un sujet très chaud en
ce moment on en a on en entend parler
sur presque tous les postes nouvelle et
ceci à mon avis est
la meilleure solution sans conversation
la situation restera stallion rien ne
changera ni rapide ni d'idées
innovatrices
mais voici que de plus en plus de
personnes en parlent que des personnes
comme moi j'essaie de prendre parole et
de faire partager leurs idées et c'est
comme ça que le changement commence
c'est comme ça que les écoles
deviendront plus sécuritaire et c'est
comme ça que les états unis obtiendront
le contrôle sur les armes à feu juste
prédit la marche étudiante dans quelques
semaines match fou où les étudiants 77
assez nous devons exprimer notre point
de vue sur qu'est-ce qui se passe
les artistes qui composent des chansons
sur l'association qui manifestent avec
leurs paroles leur frustration face à la
situation qui démontre leur compassion
pour les parents les amis qui ont perdu
quelqu'un de proche
et tout ceci a commencé avec une
conversation nous changeons les choses
grâce à nos paroles et grâce à nos
actions
et c'est comme ça que le gouvernement
ait forcé d'agir peut-être avec des
solutions que nous espérons mais il agit
néanmoins et tout ceci à cause que
quelqu'un a commencé une conversation et
c'est comme ça que j'aimerais terminer
mon discours ce soir en vous disant que
tout problème non seulement les
fusillades sont contre et avec la
conversation
c'est à cause d'une personne n'a eu le
courage de soi monter sur scène ou juste
partager leurs idées avec leurs amis que
l'ira du changement et c'est comme ça
que j'espère que les fusillades
deviendront quelque chose du passé merci
[Applaudissements]